you really don't know who I am genie
wishes land
none of that ringing about the new
Aladdin trailer gave us our first full
look at Will Smith as the blue genie and
the internet really went in on it and
there's no one I'm going to talk about
it with more than Danny went in you know
I just feel like we don't deserve Will
Smith I'd felt like Will Smith didn't
deserve this he's been trying to pull
everyone up with his Instagram stories
every day he tries to pull us up
collectively as a whole you know I got
to make it clear here I'm not I have
nothing against Wilson I love him I
think he has an angel descended from the
heavens to crisis or a genie or a genie
but that was that was jarring that was
jarring for me this is how I feel about
it I I think that if because people are
like oh they didn't have to make him
blue look look if they didn't make him
blue the internet would complain if they
didn't make him buff the internet would
complain they're gonna complain no
matter what hmm really and then I also
heard comments that people were like
it's not like Robin Williams now if you
want a winner
just be yourself I'm like it shouldn't
be no you know when people were like oh
he's just gonna play Will Smith well
that's why he was hired right I just I
understand that
I also think it's hard to judge an
entire movie based off of two seconds I
think we got two seconds with him so I
understand the concern but I think the
internet would complain no matter what
really I agree I mean I do think the
image that they released the one that's
back there looks great yeah it was just
like seeing an emotion it looked like
one of those like deep fake things that
you see where they like put some a face
on somebody else's baby yeah I think
also his they did that cover story
forgot what magazine and I thought that
he looked good in that as well when he
wasn't blue oh yeah yeah yeah yeah but
either wit maybe he'll be on and off
he's a genie he could be anything he
said and also in Aladdin the animated
Robin yeah he goes in and out of being
who of different people yeah plays
different people like a reporter
you know a small child so I think that
will get on your back guys we saw what I
think that'll be really funny to have
Will Smith playing those like an old
woman or whatever yeah I think that
that's gonna be really cool
I I don't I don't know I I wish that the
internet would not I understand the need
to but this is like something that is
common I guess I don't think I would
have a show if we didn't act like this
that's true that's true but I do I think
the biggest thing that I don't want
people to say is it's not like Robin
Williams that's what I hear a lot from
Heath Ledger when of his Joker when
people do the Joker I'm like that's
great
he already did it perfectly it exists
perfectly we don't need to see that
again
I want to see somebody else's take I
want someone to take a risk and I want
them to bring their own miss to the
character I don't want someone to
pretend to be somebody that did it
already you know is the genie a daddy I
think he is I think he's literally a
sugar daddy he grants wishes we were
also talking about Jafar who is a dad
and they made a young Jafar yo he's
younger yes because in the animated it
always creeped me out that he was like
obsessed with jasmine and then white
kisses her whatever she kisses him but
now I'm like actively rooting for this
kiss to have know that Jafar is smokin
yeah but early like in the animated
series it was like having your dad's
work friend obsessed with you and it was
just like oh no you work with my dad and
now but now he's a young Daddy Jafar yes
Daddy
we have officially come yeah daddy can't
have and I'm curious to see the Sultan I
mean I don't know have we seen I don't
think so okay yeah it would be very
interesting if Disney had Jasmine run
off with Jafar I'm here for it I'm
totally here for it yeah I think I'm
rooting for them yeah but I think like
the genie part of the trailer distracted
from the fact that that trailer was
awesome up until that moment for me yeah
because the cable wanders looks amazing
Jasmine looks amazing we saw Raja like
in the back
and then we saw boo to all we saw the
boo and then we saw the hands which we
know is the do you trust me moment oh
yeah
that's any ah go oh yah go yeah yeah in
the beginning yeah maybe that is part of
Disney's marketing I don't know like
everybody's talking about the film now
which is cool it's better than not
talking about it and a hundred percent
people are still gonna see it as much as
they complain they're still going to see
it because they want to see it that me
what ends up happening why I just knock
on things I love constantly that's like
my whole branch oh of course
yeah I'm sure you make fun of Star Wars
and like I thought you loved it I'm like
no idea but that's the thing is like
it's your little brother it's because
you're so passionate and you love it and
it's like I can make fun of my dorky
brother you can't yeah yeah you go
outside of the fandom but like us inside
of it that are heavily invested like
it's okay if we make fun of it yeah it's
like keeping it in the family and I have
to wonder too cuz that that genie shot I
almost felt like it was maybe not
completely what its gonna look like yeah
I think you're right I think you're
right yes sometime yeah they have time
and also we do know I think that the
filmmakers listen to feedback to some
extent and there have been cases where
people have said we don't like this and
or you know like maybe are you all the
way done and and they've gone back and
been like no this is what it really
looks like and people have been excited
about it well if you want to see a
really cool animated Danny oh my gosh
yes well breaks it in that I think
that's the coolest thing ever is is you
can get it everywhere tomorrow till
tomorrow yeah I didn't mean to do that
thank you
yeah it's out everywhere where you buy
movies or rent them so we're are
thinking million places where we can
find you um I'm at miss Danny Fernandez
on all the things and check out my show
neuro deficit it drops weekly wherever
you get podcasts all right well Cheers
we're okay with it where are we are okay
we are okay I got months baby mm-hmm I
need one that says daddy Oh